uh ross tucker joins the show ross
tucker podcast of course because during
the break when i said hey chris tell me
some stuff on ross he said all big t
swift guy big taylor swift guy so uh
kindred spirits here ross i love t-swift
how you doing man what's your favorite
track
i i am doing great um and uh i would say
wildest dreams
yeah it's an emotional one it's
emotional to see your connection too to
team usa soccer and the netflix
documentary very slept on you get a
chance to see the netflix documentary
that was at sundance about taylor swift
i did yeah i i'm look i i first of all i
i feel like i always have to disclose
this right she's from my hometown oh
sweet okay
so she's from wyomissing pennsylvania
i'm good friends with her dad
and i i have met her a couple times and
been in her her motor home and whatever
and she's a excellent young lady
always nice to me and my wife but
that said i really do think her music is
unbelievable like when i'm at when i'm
outside with my daughters like we put on
taylor swift radio you know whether it's
like spotify or pandora or whatever
right
and we are rocking it out i mean i just
think she is an amazing
songwriter and i i relate to her music i
don't i mean i i just enjoy i think it's
a lot better than a lot of other stuff
that people tend to like no and ross the
reason why i knew we would become
friends is because i simply asked you
did you see the netflix documentary and
you told me you hang out in her trailer
so yes
i knew that uh that we would be
interested in the documentary and i
think it's interesting like the whole
thing where she decided to make a
political tweet or whatever i i
i think that's very interesting the
whole dynamic uh behind the scenes yeah
of course i saw that man come on come on
yeah brock when you saw that come on
right opening night are you downloading
on netflix come on ross tucker joins the
show ben lyons in for rich on the rich
eisen show uh let's talk a little
football while we have you phillip
rivers thinking about coming out of
retirement possibly you know your own
career obviously ended uh you know far
differently but just this idea of philip
rivers still thinking like he might have
something left in the tank what's that
process like you think for him
well first of all it's sort of uh
kind of feels very farvian for him to
put that out there
you know like here we are it's like two
days after the colts quarterback has
surgery
that this story comes out i mean the
timing is just
very interesting i'm not mad at him for
it you know i think it's crazy like
let's let's let's flush this out for a
second okay
obviously he's committed to coaching the
high school football team i'm pretty
sure they have assistant coaches and
that
if philip wanted to leave that they
could handle it so i i think he could do
it but you know a couple years ago when
i was doing the eagles
i did the eagles preseason games every
year a couple years ago when they got
josh mccown
josh mccown
would do like even last year during
covet josh mccall would just do zoom
meetings during the week
and then after his sons played high
school football friday night he would
fly back you get there late friday night
be there saturday sunday do the game and
then fly out again
you know if you're the colts and let's
say you think wence
is only going to miss two games or four
games whatever it is
does it make sense to trade for nick
foles or one of these other guys
or does it make sense to try to work
something out with rivers where he can
like zoom during the week and fly in on
the weekends and play i mean he was on
the team last year he started every game
last year he knows the offense i don't
know maybe that's a better option than
jacob houston
no it's a wild situation because as a
professional athlete the idea that you
are comfortable with putting your career
to bed and move on with the next stage
of your life and then the door opens up
again and now you're kind of in this
limbo and thinking about well maybe i do
have something left in the tank and
you're right from the colts perspective
if they think wence is going to be back
in week two or four then why you know
move heaven and earth to go out and get
nick foles i don't think carson wentz is
coming back that soon they're talking 12
weeks that could be well you know into
the season and into november
um
if if that is the case do you think that
opens up them up possibly to a trade
situation
maybe but it's interesting cause i
actually interviewed greg cosell who i
have a lot of respect for the nfl films
guru for the raw sucker podcast and
he made the point he'd rather he'd
rather if he were the colts he'd play
jacob easton
over trading for nick foles i mean first
of all
foles has guaranteed money in each of
the next two years
and it's not cheap number one number two
he's gotten benched
back-to-back years he got benched for
gardner-minshew two years ago in
jacksonville after jacksonville gave a
boatload of money he got benched this
past year for mitch trubisky who's now a
backup making like 1.5 million
in buffalo i mean
it's not a great recent track record for
falls although i will say this
because of that guaranteed money is
contract i give the bearers so much
credit
i mean they literally had the guy do a
press conference on monday when's the
last time a third string quarterback did
a press conference but it's like the
news comes out that wench needs surgery
and it'll like fire up the nick foles
third string press conference so fools
can say i'm better than i was when i was
a super bowl mvp and i'm ready to go i
mean it was i actually give the like the
bears are desperate to get rid of that
contract ross it was amazing the only
thing missing from falls was like a
giant boombox like hey frank come get me
i'm available i want to play for you
it was so i mean seriously like uh get
somebody in research to look up the last
third string quarterback press
conference play like tebow 10 years ago
like i mean quite easily since when do
third string quarterbacks have a a
a uh
press conference like that and then
what's funny is like
that is not nick foles personality at
all i've never heard him talk like that
he's usually like so reserved so quiet i
mean he was like a different guy
ross tucker joins the show host of the
ross tucker football podcast ben lyons
in for rich on the rich eisen show
uh ross as someone who over the years
has been identified as someone who loves
to compete do you get jacked up and
fired up seeing guys put on pads for the
first time this week
yes i do um i
you know
it always sounds a little bit bad when i
say this but
more than the camaraderie
more than
even the money like i really honestly
miss the violence
you know like i work out
and i try to push myself
it's not the same dude it's not the same
as running into another dude as hard as
you can
and knocking them over or trying to
knock them over
it's just such a pure primal feeling
that once it's over
it's over like you can never do it again
and i i miss it every day i mean i
daydream about someone like
i don't know pushing my wife in a bar
not hard but hard enough that i can like
crush the dude
i can legally hit somebody like
something where i'm legally allowed to
respond with force but i don't want
anything real bad to happen to anybody
but i want to be able to unload on
someone i mean i've thought about
starting a business where like people
like you band and brockman can line up
for a hundred bucks you put a helmet
shoulder pads on and you can just run
and just lay out some dude i don't know
who the dude's gonna be but just lace
like i feel like we would make millions
once you have that feeling once you're
like honey i gotta go
where you going i gotta go to ross's
place again where i can go knock out a
dude i'm so mad i had a terrible day at
work let me go lay a couple guys out
i'll be right back
i mean the first world fight club is
ross
have you thought about challenging
someone on tick tock are you calling out
youtubers and comments looking to live
stream fight someone is that in your
future
no interest in anything that could cause
any injury or pain to me
because i've i've done that so therein
lies the rub right then like i i want
the positive of it i i want to go
lay somebody out in any capacity like i
just want
i don't want to injure someone but i
want to hurt like i want to cause them
discomfort
and i enjoy doing that but i know what
that entails i mean i had a back surgery
am i created with my neck being
herniated bruised spinal cord did my
right mcl like i'm not doing that like
that's the other thing too i always
think about
now which is so interesting like knowing
what it does to your body like when i
see some of these guys like in their
12th year
and they've already made 40 million
bucks and they sign a one year like one
and a half million dollar contract i'm
always like i mean on the one hand
that's a million half dollar like that's
a ton of money on the other hand
it's probably not going to make a
difference in their life they've already
made a lot of money but
whatever added wear and tear to their
body and whatever injury they suffer
this year that actually is going to have
a big impact on the rest of their life
yeah but i would imagine they realize
like you have that you can't line up on
a sunday and run someone over and this
is the only shop in town until your
business opens up where you can do that
so i think that's probably the
motivation for some of those kind of
guys
i i think it's a big part of it like i
still to this day okay
and if this is wrong i don't want to be
right
i do a lot of college games for cbs
sports network i will typically try to
find
a high school game like i'll drive
around on a friday night whatever couch
town i'm in and i'll just look for
lights like i'll just look for lights i
call it find the light
i'll look for lights i always have to
get there before the national anthem so
that when they play the national anthem
and everybody and i look down at the
high school kids my eyes fill up
like there aren't very many things in
life that make you do that and
that emotion
that experience
um i just think it's so special
so pure and if i can get it without any
drugs or anything i just go drive to a
high school football game on a friday
night it's pretty good
ross sucker joins the show ross tucker
football podcast former offensive
lineman and like i said a guy who loves
to compete i was right this guy is
exactly all civilians were never
introduced that way i never said oh yeah
it was great working on the rich eisen
show chris brockman producer a guy loves
to compete always there with the stats
and information you never you never hear
us civilians described that way ben he
does that like every time i'm on
chris and i will get into some like
argument or debate i can't remember what
it was before and then like chris likes
going at it
chris chris has a little edge to him oh
i love it massive edge always compete
i've ruined so many family bowling
outings over the years because you know
one goes in the gutter and i lose it um
romanticize when it's michael jordan
playing ping pong at the olympics but
it's chris brockman on a family weekend
come on it's not the same thing it's not
fun i mean i flip over the chess board
like get out of here ross looking at how
you're viewing training camp what are
some overarching
intense storylines that you're looking
at nflc what's really
caught your eye and got your focus
so i will say this i think the most
intense thing right now and i'm probably
going to write about this in my column
next week so make sure you're following
me at raw sucker nfl
i think the dynamic
during the season guys
when
unvaccinated guys
and i'm not making a judgment on that
although we could but when unvaccinated
guys
miss games
wow
like
okay so i've been in situations where
during a season
there's no you're always playing with
something
and guys will get frustrated if there's
a guy that's not playing through an
injury
that they think the guy might be able to
play through
but they also understand you know it's
not easy to play
period let alone if you got a sprained
mcl or a broken thumb like they kind of
get it and also it's the guy's career
and okay like it's his career he doesn't
want to go out there and perform at less
than his best
i kind of get that
i feel like
you know like the vikings right cousins
is not vaccinated and if you look
there are different rules
for how much time you miss
whether you're a close contact or
whether you test positive
based on whether you're vaccinated or
not so like i i this thing's going to
come to a head i feel like how
frustrated would you be
during this season
if you're starting quarterback or
whoever
it doesn't even test positive they're
just like a close contact or something
but because they're unvaccinated
they miss 10 days they miss like two
games
i mean that's not the same
as having an injury you can't play
through that's like
it's willingly making a decision to not
be available and again i'm not making a
judgment i'm just
very curious to see
hey how that goes over
in the locker room but b what about the
fan base yeah exactly that was like
you can tell by the way which guys are
vaccinated or not because when they're
in a press conference whether they're
wearing a mask or not they don't have to
wear one if they're vaccinated they do
if they're not but like you can tell so
i mean i'm from outside of philly like
like if a guy if a star player
missed a couple games and people realize
it's because they're not back like
people are going to go nuts
no it's a great point ross and it feels
like it's something that's waiting for
us as football fans just around the
corner and no one's talking about it yet
is that this could be the sort of
defining story line of the upcoming nfl
season um and you're going to be writing
about it in your new column
yeah i'll be writing about it next week
uh that that's the plan
for right now i wrote about uh
belichick's big miscalculation
last week brockman didn't read it yet
but he should
uh biggest miscalculation of bill
belichick's career by far what resigning
cam newton
i know you hate cam i know that the
thing is i don't hate camps i actually
say i actually lost for chris because
mello is a laker cardiac kimbo is in new
york it's just been a tough day for him
he doesn't know who jadakiss is he's
phil's on the outside looking about this
before uh we talked about this before
the draft brockman just did not want to
roll with with cam oh no you know what
it is brockman did not want jimmy g
yeah i didn't want jimmy g
like broccoli's not a typical fan
but he is in the sense that like
he just wanted something new like he
just wanted something different and new
passion i've been driving down i've been
having and you guys exactly
you got i had a minivan for so long and
i just wanted a new car that's totally
fine but like don't bring back the old
car if you're just gonna buy a new car
so like why bring back cam if you were
just gonna draft a quarterback in the
first round which everyone knew you were
gonna do anyway i told you ross the guy
loves to compete because the answer is
they didn't know i mean what if mac
jones went three to the niners like they
didn't know who would be available there
so
cam is cam is like insurance man like
that cam is insurance that's not that
high priced insurance
and i don't know i i tend to think it'll
be mac jones
sooner rather than later but by the way
the the miscalculation you got to read
the whole thing but the miscalculation
for belichick wasn't just moving on from
brady i really think guys
and brockman in particular i really
think
he
did not place enough value
on uh the mental psyche
of having brady on your team
like from two standpoints number one
you know i play with a bunch of
quarterbacks right when you're late in
the game and braves on your team you
know you're going to win the game
right big difference between that and
like last year with the patriots cam
when they're like
man i i hope cam can do it i think cam
can do it when you have brady and
immediately got transferred to the bucks
you know you're going to win and then
obviously they didn't win every game but
those guys thought they were gonna they
they knew in their mind we're gonna win
this game we got great we got the guy
and then the other thing is and i've
seen
some bucks players talk about this and i
experienced this when i was in new
england
brady is just such a psychopath
that you don't want to make a mistake
because you don't want to let him down
in other words
i think belichick thought we've
established the culture here over 20
years it's the patriot way and he's the
king of negative reinforcement and he
plays the first five eight o'clock team
meeting he has the five worst plays the
day before you don't want to be on that
blah blah blah but that's not the same
as not wanting to let down
a guy you love and respect as an awesome
guy
you just you don't want to i mean when
even in practice brady would look at me
and be like all right ross you and me
great snap first and i was 26 27 i
started 25 games my fifth and sixth year
in the league but when brady said to me
like
i wanted to have the best snap of my
life as a center right and that wasn't
because the patriot way or because i
thought belichick would rip me no i
didn't want to let down tom and i've
seen all the coaches in tampa talk about
that the players in tampa talk about
that they lost that new england tampa
got that and that like accountability
i it's hard to put a value on that and
whatever belichick whatever value he put
on it he didn't give it nearly as much
value as it deserves
ross tucker joining the show the ross
tucker football podcast we hope you uh
enjoy the rest of your afternoon roll
the windows down maybe play that taylor
swift song run gives me goosebumps every
time man great to have you on the show
and you know what ben let me up last
thing okay
when when people make fun of me for
taylor swift
to your point with the tick tock thing i
always say to them
as long as you sign a waiver i'll meet
you at the playground i'll come with a
boombox playing whatever taylor swift
song you want
you can come with your metallica or ac
dc
i will smoke you and laugh and leave
with my taylor swift song playing thank
you
ross sucker and a taylor swift versus
against somebody who's a metallica fan
would be fantastic ross we appreciate
you checking in and i look forward to
being best friends with you the rest of
my life thanks man sounds good see you
dude see you buddy see you dude
ross tucker ross tucker football podcast
the ross tucker rage room like how do we
get on the exclusive beta testing hey
honey what'd you do this afternoon well
i did the show and then i uh went over
to ross's gym and i ran over some guys
and now i picked up the groceries and
then what should we cook for dinner hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here